so let me introduce our
contestants today uh at the far end
there politically or otherwise we have
rich hickey
the author of closure he's an
independent soft yes yes okay
enough of that enough of that he's an
independent software designer consultant
and application architect
with over 20 years of experience and
he's worked in all kinds of stuff
actually
from scheduling systems broadcast
automation
audio analysis and fingerprinting so be
careful
database design yield management and so
forth
next we have jeremy askanas and i
apologize for all this page flipping
so jeremy works for the interactive news
team at the new york times as well as
he's the lead developer for document
cloud which helps news organizations
analyze and publish the preliminary
source documents behind the news
not to be confused with wikileaks i'm
presuming
he also created he also created
coffeescript
the uh which that yes coffeescript yes
um and he's worked with a number of
really great tools in javascript that
i've had the privilege to use like
backbone.js
underscore js stoco jamet and ruby
processing among other things
next is gerald sussman and contrary to
popular belief
he was not made in martin minsky's lab
in 1964 from surplus radio parts
nor was he part of a freshman project in
artificial intelligence he was indeed
born
but he was actually an undergraduate as
well as now a professor at mit and he's
been there since 1964 which apparently
makes him a lifer
and he's worked on amazing number of
things from artificial intelligence
languages architectures and even like
physics and astrophysics and
as a recovering physicist i actually
have a copy of his structured
interpretation of classical mechanics
which like an idiot i forgot to bring
with me to have him sign
he's also a supervised many students
and he's well renowned in national
academy of sciences and all that he's
and he's also interested in watchmaking
clock making and amateur telescope
making
among other things and of course you all
know that he wrote structured
interpretation of computer
programs with hal abelson and julie
sussman
yes all right
alan wurstbrock is the mozilla research
fellow and he's currently spends most of
his time thinking about the future of
javascript which is a great thing to be
thinking about because it's so hot
he was the project editor for the ecma
script five and whenever i see that
written i always think it should be
pronounced eczema script
um he's also a reformed small talker who
uh uh as he puts it was at the technical
he was a technical and entrepreneurial
leader during its slow rise and rapid
descent
as a mainstream programming language yes
and i remember oopsle in 95 when that
happened
um which one
[Laughter]
i think was more the decline slide then
but he has been involved in language
implementations uh and he's done a lot
of work
everything from like virtual memory
hardware to writing business
applications using rpg
all right joe palmer is one of the lead
developers on the f sharp project he's
been at microsoft for six years now i
was talking to him earlier used to live
in manhattan and then
moved to the rainy northwest and you
have to give microsoft credit they've
really embraced functional programming
and provided really first-class support
for the language so that's something
that we can all be thankful for
and last but not least is uh andre
alexandrescu who is um
responsible for coining the term uh
modern c plus plus
used to describe you know the ways that
we should be using c plus plus today and
that is not an oxymoron
and he wrote a book called modern
sequels plus design generic programming
design patterns applied
and he's worked a lot with herb sutter
on kind of evangelizing good practices
and code standards and things like that
most recently though he's been involved
with the d
language sort of working side by side
with walter bright the creator of it
and helping design key language features
um libraries and so forth
and he has a new book coming out soon
called the deprogramming language
he also has a phd from my alma mater
which is the university of washington
pardon me
it's already out all right well rush out
immediately and and pick it up
um any uh he's got his bs and double and
double e from the university of
polytechnic and bucharest
all right let's give our steam panel
okay so this is what we're going to do
you guys are going to ask most of the
questions but i'm going to
use my prerogative to ask the first
question there'll be a couple of people
roaming around with mike's and i'll just
go back and forth
across the room so the first question is
what is the capital of assyria
it's nineveh okay let's move on to the
next question which is
what is the worst idea it was ever
introduced into programming languages
that continues to afflict us today
and how can we make money on keeping it
going
and please in any order feel free to
jump in go ahead
too many parentheses in a programming
language oh
[Music]
oh snap oh snap
well it's really very hard to find the
worst idea because there are so many bad
ideas in programming languages
of course the um the ones that bother me
unless the ones that are designed to
keep me from doing what i want
i was after all about libertarian
programmer okay and so
i don't want anybody to tread on me but
the worst features of languages that i
can think of the really worst thing
is complex syntax okay and
the as as
alan perlis quipped syntactic sugar
yields cancer of the semicolon okay
one the problem with complex syntax
is that it hides possibly important to
understand mechanism
but more importantly it makes it very
difficult to write programs that
manipulate programs that
read them that write them and analyze
them and that
in fact that's and in fact i often have
programs that write programs that i want
to run in line
for example numerical programs that are
constructed from symbolic
algebra expressions okay so that's a
nice feature
of lisp for example which has lots of
parentheses is as uniform representation
of programs as data
and the ability to execute a code that
you've just constructed
and as a consequence i would say my
mantra here is
syntax without representation is tyranny
[Applause]
uh i think the worst idea is having
mutability by default unlabeled
mutability is the worst idea
that we still suffer from today
you saw that coming and to uh
echo a little bit sort of an opposite
from eric meyer who yesterday talked
about how
mathematicians are always coming to the
rescue when we run into trouble in
programming i'd like to say that i think
that mathematics envy is
some of the worst stuff that happens in
uh computer science
and that the
so um one of the worst ideas i think
is um programming in source files
uh which almost all the languages we use
but a few languages that have come and
largely gone
didn't uh so when you write code
in a source file your attention is
focused on the organization and
structure
of the information in that file and how
the pieces in the file relate to each
other
when you construct code in a small talk
environment for example
you think about the individual
abstractions and how they relate to each
other
not how the source code is represented
so it's not like there isn't source code
behind it and that it's saved and
maintained and you can version it but
your focus is directed
on the abstractions not on not on the
notation
i'm trying to remain so pessimistic
about this i think that's really one of
the big problems with
programming today is that it's actually
a great time to be a programmer
you know we have super fast machines
abundant resources great languages
virtual machines that make development
of new languages you know relatively
straightforward
relatively straightforward and lower the
barrier to entry um
but if i had to be forced to pick
something i would say that it's really
the focus on
code and not data it's on what we're
doing and
not what we're doing it for or what
we're doing it with
i hope i get the second shot that was a
joke by the way right
it's understood okay particularly
because um professor sussman is here
um i have um
as um as mostly a
sort of software engineer in the
trenches
my view is that much more concrete i
totally agree with
the complexity that the the stance on on
complex syntax or default mutability
those being taken in the concrete i
think there are
a few um simple
minute ideas that are pretty bad and
still living today
one would be uh dynamic scoping for
example of
symbols which is you know it's it's
totally anti-modular
and another would be um for example
implicit
definition of symbols like you assign
something to symbols brings into life
which is the case in many scripting
languages it's not an additional it's
not a big effort to actually
define a symbol with this feature in toe
you get into sort of a typo oriented
programming which is pretty
damaging well the correct answer is
nulls
all right he's next i see a hand back
there
we got a mic near him daniel
this ought to be good
so what concepts and constructs
are the most important to express in a
programming language
you know now and future what what is
really needs to be the focus of
programming language design
in terms of concepts and constructs
[Music]
functions and data
okay
i guess we have a winner
with data
functions as data
all right any other prepositions you
want to slip in there
data as functions here we go
okay next question maybe from this side
anybody over here
don't be shy yes sir i can repeat it if
we don't have a mic nearby
so if i can paraphrase and correct me if
i get this wrong but he's
you know excel is argued to be the most
common programming language in the world
for example very user accessible but not
programmer accessible so how can we
expand
the capabilities of languages like that
for reuse
and to get some of the benefits that we
enjoy as programmers
is that a first okay
well i don't i don't know if you
mentioned that i used to work for
microsoft so
it's uh of course you're supposed to
push your data into sql server and your
right activex can
wrong decade but uh so
so it's not clear to me that
we should expect the same language
that's used for
for that sort of programming to actually
scale
to to large-scale software engineering
projects i think if you
try to do that you get uh
you get a language and tools that are
neither good
for the casual programmer nor are they
good for the for the professional
programmer
so i think if you need to be able to
scale
data i think it's or move information
and even algorithms between those it's
important to have
define some sort of unit of interchange
or encapsulated unit
so in one sense um i'm not being totally
facetious as saying well you need to
push your data into sql server in other
words you need to be able to get your
data
out of those into a form that that can
be accessed by more professional tools
this week it might be json and but
you know some form and i think you need
to be able to encapsulate
pieces of algorithmic functionality that
can be incorporated into those
environments hence the activex control
but uh
yeah i mean i think that there's really
there's sort of two problems at play
one is the fact that i mean you have all
this data out there and it's structured
and
you know there there is sort of a
parallels you can draw between the
structure of the data and
say like what we normally do as
programmers in terms of introducing
types and modeling programs after types
and
so there are things that we can do to to
sort of make that mapping of data to
types more straightforward which would
in turn make
programming tasks more straightforward
as well um then on the other side of the
coin you have well then how can you find
meaning in the data right where
if it's not specifically about the data
or the types the it's about the
operations that you perform on the data
and then
how do you make those operations
sufficiently generic where you can map
those to multiple data sources that may
not have the same
ontology say um and i think all the
pieces are played today to do these
things it's just a matter of putting
them together i mean
you know we have things like json which
are you know kind of
more generalized serialization formats
um you know if you look at the way like
say like a table-based database is
structured i mean it's basically there
are types there they're just kind of
waiting to get out
and then the other end you have things
like you know link and and other
language features that are present today
to sort of make
walking that data and operating on a
more straightforward so it's really you
know as language designers kind of a
one of the tasks is to figure out how to
sort of coalesce those and make it a
more pleasant experience to use those
but still at the end of the day have
reusable components that
we can leverage elsewhere so i
i think one thing we want to be very
careful not to do is impose
the concept of types as
as software engineers or computer
scientists or functional language
designers
understand them and try to impose that
concept
upon the casual programmer who's just
working with with with data
and has no understanding of those
technical concepts and are
they really of no relevance to them
so whether whether it's types or json
unfortunately with this particular excel
problem it's not just a matter of
getting your data out and often cases if
you talk to people who work for like
consulting firms and stuff they spend
all day building
immense amounts of code and basically
scripting entire applications
sort of on top of excel so there's a
matter of getting the code out as well
well one thing it seems to me very
important to help people who
are manipulating data that are not
actual programmers
is the ability to for them to attach
provenance information that gets tracked
to the data that's very important for
deep reasons
that in fact people make mistakes and
they have mistakes have to be uh
be able to be found and and fixed and
the other thing i think is important is
to prevent terrible disasters like
uh that often occur when you don't have
units and dimensions attached to the
data
uh there's another kind of so you need
that kind of extra information
which of course you don't have to put in
i don't want to again
impose my will on anybody else but it
would be helpful in many cases for that
to be the case
and i although i am i'm rather
libertarian i would worry about things
like excel being able to support sort
a column without sorting the old
everything correctly and therefore
mixing up your data in some horrible way
okay
from a pure linguistic perspective i
think you know i've seen this
at work many times essentially it's we
have this great dsl
domain specific language uh and how do
we make it more of a
general purpose language and always the
path is very tenuous
because you know there are several
reasons for it
um everybody who's seen a 10 000 lines
make file
could a test right everybody who's seen
a you know a 5000 line script
could attest um do you know like visual
programming
right you assemble blocks into programs
you know how many times have people
tried to make those into
actually uh viable propositions for
for the programmer they never they never
succeeded we have
actually a great uh research project at
university of washington led by a friend
of mine
and essentially he's been teaching this
to undergrads for years
but they've been unable to get get it
from the from the point where
you can actually build an rgb color out
of three colors
to to the point where it was viable as a
programming environment
so i think linguistically excel
is very good at numerix uh it's pretty
bad at typing
referred to uh you know units dimensions
dimensional analysis and everything
uh which is missing um but it's not
going to be
viable as a programming language in in
the large
and this this probably gets a little bit
away from the actual question that was
asked but gets back to alan's initial
point about
how you know the worst idea in
programming languages is having
your code as text you know as writing
and i actually think that it's
tremendously
hopeful and uh that the fact is that you
know out of all the fields that should
have been revolutionized by
computer assisted design right you have
architects using autocad to design
buildings and you have
you know even you know illustrators and
designers using tools like photoshop to
sort of structure
their drawings and their illustrations
their designs but programmers still
write plain text that you could print
out on a printer and read
you know and understand and we're not
doing it in some sort of
computer-assisted fashion
i think that says a lot about the power
of the written word and also the nature
of programming in that
you know if you have the right
abstraction then it's just as convenient
for you to
say it as a word as it is to have some
sort of a
visual analysis that can show you where
it exists inside of your program
okay when we take the next question well
it's quite likely that i'm going to give
you this
it's likely that within this decade will
have computers that have 100 cores
and mixed processors gpus
vector processors and so on
how do we harness this power as
programmers
what kind of programs do we write
okay um so so i have my answer um
we already have systems like that um
all of us are connected right now into
into such a system and most of us are
building applications that work in the
context of such a system that
physically they are not on a single chip
or in a single box but they're
distributed over wide parts of the world
but the fundamental concepts that are
involved in building complex
web-based apps distributed applications
can be scaled down
to local machines as well as wide area
machines
um i don't want to jump the gun here um
this is a difficult problem you know as
a community we don't have an answer to
it that would be the short answer
uh the longer answer is uh there's two
uh
the way i see there's uh you know as
yogi berra said there's a fork in the
road and we're gonna take it
um so essentially there's two uh there's
two prongs to this one is the
distributed aspect of
uh you know distributed services and
computation
and the other is uh the way i see it is
uh
kernels that are highly specialized and
doing highly useful work
and uh by this i'm talking about things
like speech recognition
artificial intelligence machine learning
at the in the large
uh which are going to actually solve
very difficult problems that are of high
use to us
for example imagine you have in your
cell phone i predict within uh
within the this decade uh we're gonna
have a personal secretary
in inside the cell phone and connected
with all the other secretaries
virtual secretaries are out there and
you're gonna say what's my next meeting
and uh you know the assistant is gonna
is gonna answer
you're late [ __ ] right and stuff like
that so
um essentially um speech processing and
natural language processing are
extremely high intensive uh
computation which can be seen as a large
kernel
that is going to essentially need to run
on a highly parallel machine we don't
know
exactly how uh you know per um per
professor assessment uh
talk last night we don't know how to
solve it in 10 steps no matter how slow
each step is we don't have to do it in
10 steps we
you know uh probably we will be able to
do it in a few billion steps on you know
many processors and we'll be happy with
that uh so this would be uh this would
be the second prong
uh highly specialized kernels that do
useful work
uh that that are going is going to
actually impact the way we think about
computing
one thing i've been thinking about that
i'm a little worried about is the
uh question if we have lots of little
desperate machines of course
as you're suggesting that are actually
specialized to do different jobs and
that's
certainly expected we're going to have
to have ways of interconnecting them
which is uh which may not
be so easy in the sense that in the
sense that we
we may not be able to agree about the
appropriate languages that they talk to
each other
so maybe what we need to do is develop
methods of
establishing protocols dynamically so
the machine
to two pieces of machinery can learn to
talk to each other
in the same sort of way that in the same
way that probably different parts of my
brain have learned to talk to each other
when i was about maybe one year
old i thought soap is going to solve
that problem
i was just going to say that
without leaping so quite terribly far
ahead
i think the very first thing we need to
do as collectively as programmers is to
stop
telling the computer how to do things
that's absolutely the very next thing we
have to do no matter what we do after
that
if we if we do that we've now
separated the problem of distributing
and parallelizing things from
the tasks we're trying to accomplish so
we have to stop telling the computer how
to do things
okay do we have a question over here
maybe yes
so is language creators which language
do you other than your own do you wish
you had created
so if i can say that for the camera so
uh which language other than your own do
you wish you'd created
go ahead there's only one answer really
lisp i mean i'm not even kidding so
lisp is the the one language that has
said the first and the last word in so
many fields it's it's pretty much
amazing
um it has introduced garbage collection
when it was
almost impractical to do it uh it it has
introduced uh
functional programming it has introduced
you know a lot of notions that
people have ever since rediscovered many
times over
so i wish i had invented lisp
and i think one of the only other
appropriate answers on this panel is
scheme
[Laughter]
scheme is a lisp
[Music]
[Laughter]
i would say uh cobalt actually because
why not
i don't think anyone else is going to
take responsibility
it's yours you can have it no really
actually i agree lisp is
is really it it all goes back to lisp
you know you can't argue with it if it
wasn't for lists we'd all be
programming in descendants of fortran uh
some of us still are but
all right when we go on this side again
one up here maybe
um i'll give you this
one of the challenges i see is i've
really loved the expressibility of
languages like lisp or closure
or haskell but one of the challenges is
uh when you're working for a corporation
and you're trying to find people who do
that work
um it's really hard it's hard to find
people with experience but it's also
hard to find people who want to
i would say push themselves to that
higher level
you know is there something you could do
if you could do something what would it
be to help i would say i don't know
raise the the reading and writing level
um
that we currently have that's prevalent
and and make it higher
for the programmers in general say that
are coming out of school
i actually don't think you solved the
problem that way i mean i think it would
be great i think people
really should spend a lot more time you
know learning more
uh but you know there was a time when
java programmers were rare
right there are going to be new things
and new things that are they're you know
it's hard to find people
to fill them uh what has to happen is
people in decision-making positions have
to be empowered
with a good rationale for doing
something different
when they are they'll make that decision
they'll
some of them will have to get over that
hump of early hires and then
when there are jobs people will learn
what they need to learn to get the jobs
one of the things that's been an
observation over a long time
is that it's often to your more to your
advantage to be like the person next to
you
than it is to have a better tool and
that's why
i think a lot of there's a lot of this
inertia
in developing getting systems that are
slightly unusual
adopted in any reasonable way
um well just pragmatically speaking also
i mean sometimes it's better to ask
forgiveness than permission
um if you're working you know especially
if you're working in a managed
environment like the jvm or
net um you know being able to factor out
various components into different
languages that are appropriate for the
task is
relatively straightforward um and also a
few things speak louder than production
code so sometimes it just
means just go ahead and get the ball
rolling and then
you know if the code is there and you
need someone to maintain it um
you know they'll learn it if it's part
of the job rather than you know train
them up on it as well
so actually i've spent a significant
part of my career most of it
pushing emerging technologies and trying
to get people to adopt them and
i guess one of the things i've noticed
over the years is that um
in practice real real organizations
that actually have to do a job don't
pick a new technology just because it's
a neat new technology they pick it
because
they have something that they perceive
as an insurmountable problem that they
need to have a solution for
and and it looks like here's something
new that might be an alternative and
that
causes them to take the risk so i really
think
it's it's a pull from there's some
problem that needs to be solved and what
people have
so you got to find that problem you got
to find that niche
i actually in the early days of small
talk adoption i think what was actually
driving it was there was a lot of
enterprises who felt they had to build
applications was with rich user
interfaces
and they got the ideas that you need
needed objects and small talk was a way
to do that
to do that because they really didn't
care about object-oriented programming
they just wanted to put windows on the
screen
my sense is much of java's traction came
about because it was
very cleverly connected to the internet
and the internet was just bursting on
the scene and these organizations felt
that they had to do something that was
relevant to the internet and they were
told java was it and so they
they tried java so that's the sort of
thing that that really i think drives
adoption
um on a personal level i think it's a
matter of uh giving personal example
um i've seen many times people are
claiming uh
you know why don't you guys uh why don't
you use this uh this new
technology technique uh approach
paradigm
etc um at the end of the day you need to
demonstrate
uh that whatever uh you know
a new knowledge you're using you know
unusual knowledge you're using is going
to make you much more productive
and for me personally this this has
worked historically
instead of uh instead of com you know
whining about it
to uh to people why aren't you people
learning
about this great thing that that i'm
using um
i focused on being more productive while
using it and
you know people are going to to make the
connection also you know this this
this thing is uh is making people more
productive so i'm going to start using
it
so um definitely there is a component
from from the top down and you know
the java javascript is definitely a good
uh a good anecdote of that
and there's also a story of the
grassroots uh kind of approach which is
yeah if you think something is better uh
use it and be better
while using it i think it's also worth
acknowledging how
amazingly little lock-in there is in
terms of technical choices when you're
talking about code compared to almost
anything else right it's not like you
have a factory and all your tools won't
fit the new widgets or your
train tracks are a little bit too wide
for the new kind of trains you have to
tear up the whole thing right
it's often the case where you can deploy
a small piece of your entire application
enclosure or in scala if you want to try
it
and just make it interoperate fairly
easily
okay why don't we get a question in the
back up here yes i see that hand back
there
yeah so it seems like there's been a
cyclic evolution of programming
languages
uh and uh features such as or concepts
such as uh
functional programming object-oriented
programming dynamic typing or static
typing have come in and out of fashion
and i'm wondering if you expect that
cycle to continue
and if not how do we break out of it um
so i have an answer um that's the nature
of humanity
whatever is currently in vogue whatever
people currently are using at some point
in time
some somebody or some group of people
starts to break out and say there's got
to be something different
you know if there there if there is no
new emerging technology there's
nothing for language designers to do
nothing for consultants to consult on so
yeah i think the
cycle is going to continue forever it's
whatever
is the established technology there will
be
new technologies that are trying to
break in and displace them
but hopefully it's something a little
bit more than just fashion right it's
not like
you know your low-rise functional
programming is in this season and then
next week
because i mean because you have you have
cycles of human interest but the same
time you have this sort of march of
technology that is kind of going in a
direction
absolutely there is is a march that
things i think do
get better but there is a lot of fashion
involved i mean i've seen enough of of
that it's in enough of these cycles to
say
to a certain degree this is simply you
know
the neat new thing and so that's why
it's being followed
i don't think it's cyclical at all and i
think the main thing
is that the technology is driving so
fast that almost everything we do
becomes obsolete rather fast
okay the reason why the reason why
functional programming has come into
vogue in
some places is because now you have
machines that can actually
do it reasonably well with you something
like lisp is a memory hog
right it's it's obviously true and so
the
the the fact that we're going to have
machines with millions of cores or
whatever which i think is true
is going to is going to require
completely different ways of programming
and that's going to require totally
novel ways of thinking
so i don't think we're really in that
loop at all yeah exactly i don't think
we should be focusing on the languages i
think
we should be focusing on the problems
we're trying to solve um
you know the problems that are i mean
there is a certain amount of fashion and
language choice today a bit but
i mean the problems we're trying to
solve today you know are
maybe better suited to to certain kinds
of languages or certain certain
approaches to problem solving um
with so necessarily since we're all
facing these problems you know we tend
to look to those tools
um so so yeah i don't think it's it's so
much cyclical i think that it's just
that you know certain problems are
more important to us at certain times
and certain tools are maybe more
appropriate
for coming with solutions to those
problems
um in india i agree it's not cyclical
it's spiral
because it cycles and it goes back to
where it was except
you know at a different point in a third
dimension
so um you know if you if you follow uh
you know any aspect of our industry
you're going to see that it follows
spirals
uh look at operating systems are a great
example because
uh it's been like microkernels and then
exokernels and
and it's going on and on and you know
virtual machine monitors have been
invoked like in the 60s
like vmware right and uh you know this
this has been going on and on in all
fields like storage
any any anything database is storage it
goes on and on you know it comes
and that's because the trade-offs in our
hardware are changing
there's a time when all memory access
was
three was one cycle right it was one
side because it was one transistor then
the
memory boss was one wire that was like
two meters long and stuff like that
right
so don't cut that wires there's a memory
bus
better don't cut that you know so um
they've been enticed when memory access
has been why cycle because the process
was so so damn slow because you know and
then uh
process got faster memory is lagged
behind
and uh the traders keep on changing on
us and that's why
different architectures and different uh
different trade-offs uh change over time
i don't think it's a it's a it's a mere
matter of fashion that being said it is
a spiral
because for example there's been great
progress in uh in uh
in programming language theory and
practice in the past uh 20 30 years
um thinking you know that there's things
that uh that are just
just great that have been done and
definitely there is there's real
progress there and if if for example um
a functional approach comes comes with a
vengeance because now you can
you have a much better grasp on
mutability control mutability
you have a much better grasp on
paralyzing things
you have much better grasp on you know
on things that made functional
programming
historically difficult so uh definitely
i would agree that
uh there is this notion of things coming
in and out of vogue but they are driven
by real market and technological forces
so i think that actually connects back
to the earlier question about what we're
going to do to address
you know having thousands of cores um on
a chip because there seems to be both
you know in the industry and then also
among the kinds of things
that we're seeing a lot of focus on
having languages that are there to fit
the technology of the time right how are
we going to
use our languages that can adapt to this
you know million core world
but at the same time i think it would
also be good to have a focus on
languages that are focused on the
problems and not so much
you know saying oh now we have new
hardware let's write in the language
that fits the hardware but doesn't
necessarily fit the problem
so you know because problems sometimes
they arise just because the hardware you
have right you've got a 10 a 20 cluster
storm server and now you need to figure
out the reach of all of your tweets and
maybe that wasn't your problem
before you had 100 machines to run it on
and in my particular case
with sort of new york times projects
it's often
not at all something that that needs to
be you know highly concurrent or highly
scalable it's more with dirty data
right you have a terrible data set from
the government you have to clean up or
you have
a whole bunch of really cruddy documents
you need to connect in some way and it's
much more about you know sort of
scripting and being able to express it
clearly than it is about any kind of
performance or type safety or
reliability so i think we need to
look at both okay i think we're out of
time do you guys have a question for the
audience
maybe not all right let's thank our
panel
[Applause]